it's been kind of quiet offseason for a
team that most people overlooked last
year as they rocketed to 12 and for
nearly won the division nearly became
the number one seed in the AFC could you
imagine having multiple home playoff
games in that undersized soccer stadium
in Carson California that almost
happened but it didn't
and now the Chargers trying to move
forward and take the next step and I
look at what they did this offseason
you know they when you look at the
Browns going all in after going 8 7 and
1 and the charge is on the brink maybe
they just think we just need to keep
treading water we'll be fine with who we
have because I don't see an overwhelming
effort to try to take that next step
Chris no no I mean I agreed I don't they
didn't kill it in free agency
I mean hey when you look at the team and
I think you would agree man there's not
there's not a lot to dislike about the
roster overall I mean there's not too
many weak points there's a reason they
were 12 and 4 I mean offensive line play
is good you know right wide receivers
you could say that's one of the better
groups at all a football they got a
great running back you look at the
defensive side of the ball man they got
to premier pass rushers on the edge with
the program and and Joey Bosa and Melvin
Ingram you know you've got a star in
Derwin James at safety
Casey Heyward a corner who's a
phenomenal football player so it really
was just about a little you know
tinkering with the the overall roster to
begin with big thing is hey you saw the
divisional playoff game right Mike one
of the issues I had with the team was
they got steamrolled by the New England
Patriots in a physical downhill type of
running football game now we saw them do
a better job against Baltimore the week
before but we also a few weeks before
that the first time they played
Baltimore they had some issues with that
same type of play so they addressed the
size of their football team the interior
part of their defensive line in the
first round I thought with Jerry Tillery
and I thought that was probably the
number one need on their roster is more
big people in the middle of that defense
so they don't have to load the box and
put themselves in compromising positions
to stop the run game then to where a guy
like Tom Brady comes off a play-action
and everybody's wide open because
there's nine guys four feet from the
line of scrimmage because they're
worried about getting beat
up in the run game so that really as a
whole was one of my only issues to go
with it but Tillery great pick second
round pick
Nasir at early from Delaware Mike man he
was a player he's a guy that I looked at
as a fringe first-round type player him
and German James in the backend has a
chance to be a very special combination
at safety their version of Earl Thomas
kam chancellor because they play that
seattle scheme defense with Gus Bradley
yeah and you know I see Easton stick the
quarterback they took in round five
surely not they're not thinking about
him the heir eventual to Philip Rivers
but that that seems to be the one big
question hovering over this team how
long is the current era at quarterback
going to last yeah what point do they
have to make that tough decision about
what is going to be the person at that
position leading them into the future
especially in the division that has
Patrick mahomes that you know and and
you have to be able to compete without
Patrick mahomes I just I just feel like
this and I hate you know maybe this is
good maybe this is what they need that
maybe teams like to be off the radar
screen or like to be overlooked and and
disregarded that's how they were last
year and I feel like that's how people
are gonna feel about them this year even
though they did have a special season
they didn't lose away from the the city
of Los Angeles until that division round
game and they beat the Chiefs in that
epic Thursday night game that made us
think for a little while yeah the team
actually is gonna be the number one seed
so III think this is perfect because you
can you you don't have to worry about
everybody's head getting puffed up and
the coach can you know poke and prod the
players saying nobody respects you
because I just feel like we're gonna
have that exact same vibe with this
Chargers team this year but I still
think they have the ability as proven by
the fact that they didn't go out and
make a bunch of major changes they have
the basic core ability to be a good team
for this year I worry about next year
but you know one thing we've learned
about the NFL over the last 25 years
next year doesn't matter
that's the Bill Belichick approach all
that matters is this year worry about
next year next year it'll take care of
itself for now we're gonna take care of
what we can take care of in the current
season yeah you're right they're flying
under the radar
I mean hey come on they get their
overlooked in their own division the
Chiefs the Raiders with a
did this year okay they're getting a lot
of notoriety they're overlooked in their
own damn City I mean come on the Rams
are the kings of LA right now I mean
they've kind of seem to drive the needle
and get more of the the overall you know
national attention either way but yeah
they say should be contented with their
roster there's a lot of things to like
this is a team that's in its window
right now it's there to be had to win
and Philip Rivers is I feel like a
little bit in that John Elway you know
swansong type part of his career where
I'm rooting for the Chargers because I
want to see Philip Rivers get to a Super
Bowl or do that
I got great respect for you know Anthony
Lynn Gus Bradley I think they're hell of
a football coach on both sides of the
football and hey Mike you got to
remember to guys like Hunter Henry who
tore his ACL last year he'll be back in
the fold so that's almost like an
addition to your football team that's
certainly gonna help and the big thing
you know you asked about Phillip Rivers
yeah I do think we're getting towards
the end he's had a great career uh you
know I've talked about it with you I
don't know you know if his the way he
throws the football is going to extend
his career into the 40s
I don't think he has the type of arm
strength and power would the way he does
throw it to where yeah they're gonna
have to answer the quarterback question
here at some point but the last two
years he's played well and he's silenced
some of those questions and come through
in clutch moments to where hey they feel
comfortable riding Phillip Rivers at
least one or two more years we're doing
an offseason examination of all 32 teams
today we had the Browns with the
Chargers the Browns according to the
folks in Vegas nine win over under the
Chargers nine and a half the bar
actually higher for the charges are you
over or under nine and a half for LA I'm
gonna go over I am I think this is it
again I don't see twelve and four but I
think the Chargers are one of the teams
that I look at that is going to get back
in the playoffs from last year one of
those teams I just think the defense has
got too much talent at some two key
positions you know Phillip Rivers the
receivers they got you know Melvin
Gordon at running back and Anthony Lynn
where his master trade is run game and
coming up with good run game design and
things of that nature to wear yeah I
look at them and still think there are
serious threat in the
say and if they can ever get lucky from
a health standpoint yeah they could be
wire-to-wire best team in the conference
and Super Bowl contender
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports